Peggy Peggy what happened
[Laughter]
wait you're not [ __ ] your PHA D your
PHA Gea's twin-brother [ __ ] do I know
what happened to your brother
it worked no they've kept you prison
here who who kept your prison oh my god
I should just keep playing along do what
counsel would be through it once there's
more people trapped did you hear
anything about the dog oh my god I'll
come back for you one day [ __ ] I'll
come back for you one day sorry Peggy
welcome back to Minecraft everyone it's
been a long time Oh Sashi brewery days
I finally I was able to play while I was
traveling home from Japan so I built a
little bit of Tower of Ikea
let me show you guys it's not finished
yet but I think it looks pretty awesome
can go up and up and up and up and up
you guys hear something anyway the view
is pretty out viewers pretty sick from
here you can just breeze down quite
easily but yeah I'll finish it at some
point okay
tower of idea will be more glorious than
any they could even topple the meatball
I don't want to get ahead of myself but
it could topple the meatball the most
holiest of all grounds cancer would be
truth has to return counselor patriot i
do thy bidding what is my task for
today's episode i should what
[Music]
are you telling me I should freak a
creeper absolutely out of the question
you've taken it too far alright gamers
so today we're gonna freak a creeper I
don't know if this has ever been done
before I don't even know if this is
legal I don't even know how you're
suppose this begs a lot of questions
where is creeper hole what happened to
this series maybe if we we trap him
right look at him here I wonder if
there's an achievement for freaking a
creeper in this game if not I'm very
disappointed in you notch okay so he
will come here little bit like hey hey I
don't think I've ever given this much
thought into anything so I'll put a okay
so we'll put an observer here perfect
then a string here creeper touch the
strings activates red signal white no
work I need a tripwire pull up was it
going the wrong way
oh my god I'm an idiot okay now it
should work yes okay okay the trap yes
tonight will be the one free okay
alright and once he's in there we'll
have to set up the second mechanism
first I need to find the creeper I found
one I found one follow me creeper oh god
what was that nothing I kind of want to
name him I feel like that that would
make it more romantic if you catch my
drift
he's still following me now can I name a
creeper I have so many questions about
once ever done thanks this is my wolf
farm by the way it's working really well
it's really efficient I'm getting a lot
of wool out of this
oh god he's literally right next to my
handle you know there's always been
something about creepers can't quite put
my finger on it maybe it's the way they
always want to blow you up
is he coming do it
Oh God look at him I'm the one creeping
on the creeper now I'll name him Ingemar
I feel like that's a freaking bull name
where'd he go and why there's anger
don't blow up yes it was like father to
me
[Music]
how can i name creeper ah this is a hug
okay next one will be named ignore the
second come on
oh my god there's so many creepers
perfect Oh God
no anger okay hey okay okay I got a name
him without him exploding is he alive
Ingmar in barrios at you anymore it's
don't blow up dammit well I'm gonna run
out of nametag if this continues I'll
name them after hey I saw one more
there's still hope
come on oh god oh god don't go there
don't go there oh okay
alright don't activate the trap so there
we go and then Ingmar now Ingmar over
here there away from what the hell what
happened to the trap he blew up the
Redstone I'm an idiot
oh god damn it yeah yes
[Music]
I'm the one getting Frick right out back
to square one back to square one
uh you want this beetroot follow me
mmm I have so much beetroot fun of me a
lot of people don't know these they love
beetroot just follow me
just follow me where is happening huh
now you I will freak a creeper hey baby
come here come here come in here come in
here follow me you semen demon okay okay
this is it
[Music]
is he following here's haha no no come
come come what in the world I need it
better I need a better trap clearly I
didn't think they'd I didn't think I'd
have to be this elaborate but I guess I
will have to being bang Bing creeper
comes creeper trapped
how do I get out follow me in bar enough
mercy oh jeez - are you in a boat oh my
no let up
oh hey mommy hey mommy
alright this is what I call a pro-gamer
mob hey baby yes yes yes yes come here
come here come here come on
come down there ah yes yes oh my god I
think I did it yes okay we just need to
put the trapdoor in front of it yes
hello
don't think so what's your name hmm
don't get too excited now look it in
look at him
fool fool this is where the fun begins
I like the teasing burn I couldn't lie I
like to tease him
I am making some adjustments huh No oh
ah
[Music]
it's like the teaming up against me
being very still safe okay he brought
his friends tell me angler nope at last
Ingmar look at me look at me
that's right tell me do you like this
mood some lights perhaps some mood
lights would you like some mood lights
Inger it's not too bright
maybe you're a bit shy with your body I
understand now tell me what kind of
speed is your preference Inger fast or
slow
why don't we start slow
[Music]
are you ready angry let's begin my god
you can't really see but there is an
iron rod going would you like some more
speeding very very well enjoy
I've got Council of beetroot waiting for
me oh my god he looks so silly
hey hey hey cancel of beetroot I have
returned I've done thy bidding please if
you know anything about my friends more
freakin I don't even know what up there
are other holes okay I guess I can I
guess I can use the old boat technique
that's a classic right surely they will
be impressed okay so to freak a creeper
with a boat this is my tutorial you just
build a line for five squares make it
even you get a you got a boat actually
needs to be eight right yeah this will
be where the piston will be so you'll
want to put the water flowing towards
there so in this corner for example you
see it's gonna be pushed towards there
so that there can be no avoidance of of
any penetrate this is just a method I
use other people probably have other
ideas and and ways to do it and
obviously there's no right and wrong way
to freak the creeper and then yeah yeah
there you have it if we can even plug it
into the same pause
I think there's something romantic about
that you know they get the field now
we're just gonna find a creeper and put
him in the boat easy don't oh god that
was close
how will I get him in the boat goddamn
you look good you're single what's your
name invite 12 Wow
what a coincidence don't hurry save
yourself oh yeah oh yeah yeah get in the
boat get in the boat damn it get in the
boat get in the boat
get in the boat I know you want to get
in the boat dress oh hey look we had the
same pace mrs. see me if I go here he
doesn't see me
he says enjoying this boat riding fool
yes enjoy yes yes perfectly censored
[Laughter]
sorry guys let me play the music they
called me a madman
now council of the truth will be pleased
oh yes they will like this one does
anyone want to look at me hey buddy hey
buddy I'm right here I'm right here
no he escaped this means you will endure
twice the pain enjoy it oh my god ha ha
you will never escape you will never
escape what's that you wanted I suppose
you had enough your friend is ready now
and now we've taken precautions haven't
we Ingram our 13 that's what I thought
in bar 13 god
they brought their family fools nothing
will save you in bar 13 nothing they
will watch they will watch the they're
watching in shock oh I see we have
volunteers how nice
oh my god
it's perfect
it looks like creeper has peepee this is
the most ridiculous surely now Council
of water sheep I mean they get rude I've
done as you command and council of
beetroot now please Oh more promise then
you will release my friends very well
but I take no pleasure in this
whatsoever this is gonna sound crazy but
what if you get two creepers in a boat
Oh perfect
follow me hey how are you what's your
name
Liza Oh follow me yes
come here yes getting boat yes very good
lights are very good now what was your
friend's name ping pong Oh Oh ping pong
hey ping pong your friend life-size over
here follow me
yeah yeah look look she's right there
yes whicka cute they are
we'll put that there on three ticks and
boom
I realize I can very easily make it even
worse
hold on what have I done
Oh God I became a literal sheep for
counsel of beetroot
I would never freaky creeper Who am I
kidding I understand what their shape I
understood your please okay brace men
top of IKEA tower what that makes no
sense but I have to finish building it
first I start a bunch of projects all
the time
what's that I always start new projects
and I never finished them like the house
that I never finished or the tower I
never finished and this series that just
keeps going but never finish
[Music]
there it is I did it I finished it I
think I understand now I used to look at
IKEA power and think best and most
beautiful Tower this world has ever seen
the most beautiful structure its beauty
radiates across the universe but I
understand now its beauty was coming
from its aesthetic no it was the
friendship that surrounded it I
[Music]
understand now but I must do
I must blow up like Kia tower I've
already made up my mind let me just take
one last look at you what was I fit pink
pink you're here say chair again you
were here all along
oh my god I was just about to blow up
Iko power and you would have blown up
with it why were you here you wanted to
teach me a lesson about finishing my
project and to appreciate friendships
instead of oh thanks guys but why here
Council of beetroot told you to stay
here
[Music]
oh my god guys
run run Schmitt gotta get
baked Venice son yard again